Here is how you can get Claude to run
your SEO 24/7 on autopilot every single
day. First, you need to download the
desktop app for Claude because we have a
little bit more features compared to the
web app mode. And then we're going to
want to go ahead and utilize our skills.
Now, skills are preset processes that
you can create and use easily in Claude
and you can do it on a weekly or a daily
basis. So, for example, I have a couple
of different skills here. First The
first skill is the backlink opportunity.
This allows the AI to go out and find
the best backlink opportunities and the
best opportunities to increase your DR
or your DA um based upon your website
and then based upon your competitors as
well. We also have the ultimate SEO
skill. Now, this skill acts as a senior
SEO consultant for any business. Use
this skill anytime the user wants to do
SEO, rank higher on Google, audit their
website, research keywords, so on and so
forth. So, essentially, this is a
complete SEO skill that will go out, do
an audit, give you actual insights to
your specific niche, to your specific
website based upon real real data that
it'll go out and search the internet or
search Ahrefs or use Chrome to get
real-life data and give you that data
and actual insights that you can do to
increase your SEO. We also have an SEO
audit skill.
This allows you to conduct world-class
comprehensive SEO audit with competitive
analysis as well. So, again, similar um
but this goes out and audit based upon
your competitors. And it's also really
really good at giving you
recommendations for on-page
optimizations for your website and also
off-page. We also have a skill that
allows you to humanize content. So, this
will humanize your content so it sounds
a little bit more uh human sounding if
you're worried about your content being
flagged as AI. So, as you can see, the
skills are Once you set up the skills,
it's easy for you to use. All we have to
do is hit the backslash and we can see
here all of her skills will pop up. We
just hit backspace and we can see all of
her skills here and for example we can
use the ultimate SEO skill and then we
can go ahead, copy over any website that
we're working on and then we don't even
have to say anything cuz the AI will
know exactly what it needs to do. So we
can go ahead, find that skill and then
do the audit based upon the website that
you enter. So very very easy for you to
do. Now the third thing that you need to
do to ensure that this happens every
single day
or on whatever schedule you like is to
use the co-work mode and then the
schedule task. Now this is where you can
hit create with Claude or you can set up
manually. So if I go to set up manually
I can give it a name, a description
and I can use the model and I can use
the frequency in which I would like it
to do. So for example, as you can see
here again, I can enter my skill.
So I can say
every
we can do hourly, daily, weekly. I can
do every week or monthly.
I want you to find new and fresh
backlink oppor-
tunities
for this site. And you put your site in.
Now what you can also do is you can also
connect MCP. So what that means is if I
head over to connectors
if I head over to customize I'll be able
to see all of the
connectors that I can connect with. So I
can actually connect with my Google
Drive. I could also if I click plus
browse connectors, I can connect to
Gmail. So I simply just go on to connect
and then I have to sign in to my
account. Right? So I can connect my
Gmail. Now once my Gmail is connected,
let's go back over to my schedule, new
task, create manually. So just pretend
that we have our same prompt and then I
can tell it to once you find the
information
send it via email to my Gmail. That's
um connected. Or you can send it to your
HubSpot, you can send it to um whatever
other connector there is in uh Claw,
which is a lot and it's growing. So, a
lot of the big tools that you use,
Zapier, Make, all of these tools are
already uh embedded into Claw. So, you
can set up a schedule, which
automatically does a audit on a weekly
or monthly basis, gets the information,
and sends it over to your CRM or to your
email. So, again, that was just one
skill that I showed you guys, but as you
can see here, you can do this with any
other skill, and you can even use Claw
to create a skill if you like. I'm
working on a new platform, which has all
of my SOPs that I mentioned in today's
video and on this YouTube channel in one
place. So, you'll be able to easily
navigate different SOPs for different
use cases using the most powerful and
relevant tools of today. You can watch
the videos, you can download the file,
and you can navigate and find whichever
SOP you need. If you want to get access
to this early platform, comment SOP
below, and I'll send you over the link.